following on from the a propeller our
video released last week or early ideas
as a division agent who was fiercely
loyal to his duty and he played a huge
role in ensuring that April made it to a
destination in this video we're going to
follow the story from Diaz's point of
view from where he first met April to
the point of taking on the black tusk
single-handedly
[Music]
[Music]
it was nearly known in agent Diaz was
overlooking the district around 58 and
Fifth Avenue from a rooftop this was
part of his regular day-to-day patrol
and from this vantage point he had an
ideal view of the surrounding streets
and barricades that were preventing
people from leaving the dark zone he
noticed a woman making her way through
the barricades and he observed her
entering the dark zone
she stopped often seeming to take in her
surroundings before cautiously advancing
down the street ordinarily he would have
approached without hesitation as only
division agents able to freely move in
and out of the quarantine zone but there
was a concreteness about this woman she
appeared collected and seemed to be
looking for something in particular
he decided to follow and keep an eye on
her she hadn't done anything wrong it's
just this was no place for civilians to
be wandering around on their own as had
been five months since the outbreak an
order wasn't exactly restored within New
York City agent Diaz was originally
activated in Washington DC but chose to
travel to New York instead where he knew
help was most needed now after all these
months he was thinking about going back
home to his children Ivan and Emilia who
had been staying under the care of the
JTF he had plans on informing the local
jtf base as soon as he completed his
Patrol but before he could do that he
had a feeling that he needed to see
where this woman was going and why she
gave the impression of someone who was
quite comfortable with making her way
through the dark zone she seemed to know
all the areas to avoid and was strategic
invading hostile groups he also noticed
the division issued backpack and super
90 shotgun she was carrying to some
agents for the backpack alone this would
have been enough to shoot her on sight
as any persons carrying division gear
are usually responsible for their agents
death and being a division agent they're
not down to the usual rules of combat
and it would be perfectly acceptable to
shoot her without knowing the full story
but to Diaz she just didn't seem the
type so he kept his distance and
continued to follow her
eventually she made it to 58th Street
and into an open storefront as far as
Diaz was aware there was nothing of
interest in its built in but he decided
to hang around for now to see what
happened he remained outside until
nightfall despite the fact that he knew
this was no place for him to be after
dark and even though he'd been on his
feet all day but just before moving on
he decided to check in with a local
safehouse and find out if there's
anything of interest at this location
that may be in the JTF database
shortly after coms replied stating that
this was the current location of Roger
Koopman the status was unclear and there
was no indication of Wales currently
being tracked by the JTF curious Diaz as
the Intel officer to find out what
Koopman was being monitored he also
decided that the woman must have turned
in for the night and he headed for the
checkpoint in the direction of the JTF
safe house and 92nd Street where it
would stay the night
Diaz was awakened ready by 7:00 a.m. the
next morning after the morning briefing
he then checked in with the Intel
officer to see if they'd found any more
information on Koopman as it turned out
Cooper had co-authored a number of
scientific papers that dr. candle and
her team were using in conjunction with
the antiviral research at all times his
location is under 24-hour surveillance
however the details behind this of a
high-level security personnel only so on
of importance wanted to ensure this NGO
was safe and accessible even if he was
hiding out in the dark zone Diaz thanked
the officer and quickly checked over the
mission board before heading off towards
the main JTTF Base located down in the
post office after using Isaac to inspect
the surrounding areas he swiftly made
his way down the outside of the dark
zone and towards the main base of
operations while Isaac couldn't see
everything in general it did a pretty
good job by using facial recognition and
uniform detection and partnership with
the JTF current database of non hostile
group locations seeing division gear he
was waved into the post office by the
guards inside Diaz met up with JT of
officer lieutenant Hendricks within the
security wing division agents only
answer to the president but as a
courtesy he was letting her know that he
was heading back to DC in the end it
didn't really matter what she thought
but he wanted to do the right thing we
keep her in the loop
Hendricks knew she had no jurisdiction
of him but asked if he could hang around
for another three days as the JTF had a
large-scale operation planned which
involves reclaiming the area around City
Hall I knew that every asset would be
required dears understood the symbolic
importance of reclaiming City Hall he
agreed to stay and would only leave if
something more urgent required as
immediate attention he figured he'd been
away from home for months so what was a
couple more days before moving out he
requested a favour from him and asked if
she could look at the JTF database to
locate his children to see how they were
doing while there are no specifics on
individuals she could see that everyone
who'd been previously staying read lived
as children have been relocated due to
flooding and we're now at the
Smithsonian castle
you
des was in the thick of it
pinning down a group of hostiles while
the main JT of force moved into place
around City Hall suddenly of the comms
came an SOS call from another division
agent the call was for help as a number
of civilians were in danger he knew he
couldn't just up and leave not until the
remainder of the JTF force was in
position or they will get caught up in
enemy crossfire once they are in
position
he left the area and headed towards the
distress call upon entering the building
he noticed he was in the center of what
was a large firefight bodies littered
the floor he quickly took in the scene
around him trying to piece together what
might have happened
he moved quickly down the side hallway
until he came across the door which he
had to force open inside he found the
civilians that agent Mike Bronson had
called in for 14 of them including six
children all did there was no sign of
Ronson but Diaz could clearly see how
this had played out Bronson had lured
the hostiles into the building and for a
time had managed to fight back however
it looked like eventually he'd been
given no choice and had to move all the
civilians into the elevator lobby where
it seems they had to be left to defend
for themselves Diaz used Isaac to
pinpoint the exact location of Ronson
since Driscoll and it was around 500
feet from the fight Bronson must have
called him or flee he'd left the
civilians to die continuing to check
over the site Diaz hoped he'd misread
the situation
but no matter which way you looked at it
Watson had let these people did for
civilians to do this will be
understandable cowardice for a division
agent those absolute treachery
Diaz struggled to halt Becker's rage he
used Isaac to locate Ronson's current
location and found him in the middle of
the Hudson River moving rapidly towards
the Jersey side deer's made his way back
to the base of operations and calmly
approached lieutenant Hendricks he
informed an avoided scene and requested
Sheila's Ronson into the system as a
rogue agent
hidden leaf she did as he asked along
with tears is report furthermore he went
on to request that she continued with
Ronson's case and look into any of his
previous communications dears believed
that he must mean following orders from
someone higher up is surely this could
be the only explanation is why he would
run out of an operation like this
Hendricks was noticeably uncomfortable
about doing this directive 51 minute
division agents weren't answerable to
the JTF issue is not a division agent
Diaz was essentially asking you to
operate well outside of her own command
network reluctantly Hendricks agreed but
informed him it would have to be later
on in the day now rather than hit back
to DC like he'd planned Diaz knew that
he had to pursue this agent who had
walked out on everything they swore to
protect this was more important right
now it wasn't until much later in the
afternoon that Diaz was able to catch a
ride with the JT of patrol boat over to
Jersey while maintaining a location on
Ronson's position using Isaac he was now
just outside of Stroudsburg Diaz
eventually managed to find transport via
a truck that was able to take him to
Harrisburg
Diez arrived in Harrisburg but because
it was getting late he made the decision
to stay the night at the local JT of the
logistics base
not long after arriving at the base his
coms paint goes Hendricks she informed
him that she'd picked up an encrypted
transmission in Ronson's comm records
the recording rate Sentinel
this is mantas intercepted comps left
Manhattan engage and assist
it wasn't Ronson's voice so he must be
Sentinel but who was mantis the
remainder of the recording went on with
a bunch of garbled noises apart from one
word Michigan this is where he needed to
be eating dears immediately check the
current location of Ronson but Isaac was
still saying he was in Strasbourg he
believed Isaac was starting to play up
which sometimes happened outside of the
big cities the next morning dears again
tried to run Ronson's location
Isaac was still returning the same
coordinates what was wrong with Isaac
and Wyatt Isaac not yet flag Demers
Rogue
shortly after Hendricks again made
contact with him she disclosed to him
regarding information that recently a
report had been put into the system by a
JTF garrison in Strasburg stating that a
division agent identifying as AI
Cranston
had gone solo in the night with the
purpose of interrupting a local group of
rebels that were planning to blow up an
estate bridge he was successful with a
live and confirmed kills and also
managed a rescue of five month-old baby
in the process confused by what Ronson
was doing he implored Hendricks to keep
digging and then continued on foot to
his destination in Michigan
three days later deers arrived in
Clearfield he was now an Amish country
unfortunately Isaac was now barely
working and his heart was completely
unresponsive deers was able to
commandeer a number of rides
via multiple horse and carts from
Clearfield to Orville once there he
swapped carts gained and headed off
towards Sandusky a 60 70 hour ride away
a few hours out from the destination
they came across a bridge suddenly four
men appeared from underneath three of
them with guns raised deer swiftly
lifted as g36 to his shoulder and
slipped off the safety they continued to
move slowly towards the bridge as they
got closer to the men raised their hands
motioning them to stop and the third
pointed an ar-15 and their direction D
as instructed the driver to wait for his
first shot before advancing the horses
quickly forward as fast as possible at a
distance of 20 yards from the men deers
took aim with his g36 and fired
incredibly difficult to fire whitman
from a moving target and surprisingly
his first burst missed even so the men
holding the ar-15 ducked haphazardly and
to cover one of the other men lipped
towards one of the horses as they passed
and managed to get a grip he swung a leg
up over the horses launchers and pulled
out his gun unable to shoot as there was
a high possibility you could have one of
the horses deers dropped his gun to the
floor of the cart and bolted himself
onto the horses back knocking the gun
out of the man's hand and then started
trying to push the man off using a
series of punches but was unable to keep
any decent leverage or on the back of a
horse by this stage the men had managed
to draw a knife and began menacingly
thrusting it in Diaz's direction Diaz
was also beginning to lose his grip and
had no choice but to let go of the
harness in order to stop a man from
stabbing him he had decided if he was
going down he was taking the attacker
with him Diaz knew he had to try and
ensure that he landed on the man when it
hit the ground so that he would take
most of the impact of the pavement
it hath whipped because of the momentum
he still managed to hurt us here as he
rolled off the man's body fortunately
though he'd come out better off than his
attacker dazed and bleeding profusely
from his head and most likely concussed
Diaz managed to climb back onto the cart
and here in the driver continued down
the roads towards Sandusky before the
other rebels managed to catch up
in Sandusky the Amish driver stitched
da's up and thanked him for saving his
life if he hadn't been there the men
would have most likely stolen everything
he was delivering and killed him too
although he was keen to keep moving his
injuries thought otherwise and Diaz
ended up sleeping in a nearby house for
16 hours straight much to his dismay
he'd lost an entire day the next morning
while heading out his head lit up with
an incoming call from Hendricks he had
been out of signal range and she hadn't
been able to contact him until now she
quickly informed him that a tech has
been compromised and she believed that
one of the booster tails had been
destroyed Hendricks were not to tell him
that she'd found out what Ronson has
been hunting down and where he was going
he was looking for a woman called April
Kelleher and that she was on her way to
another currently they had no idea where
she was headed that way the only
information she had was that she had
recorded contacts with a man named Roger
Koopman who had previously done some
research in consulting with the JTF
scientific when dears immediately
recognized the name of the man from the
same location the woman had visited in
dark zone potentially the same woman
that he'd seen several days ago before
Thompson had gone off the grid he and
Hendricks figured that Ronson must be up
to April for information about a
potential vaccine and their whoever
onsen is really working for as the power
to supply him with the technology and to
stop him from being flagged as rogue
they clearly wanted this knowledge for
themselves as the last known location of
Ronson was in Toledo Diaz knew that he
needed to get there before it was too
late and feared that he was running out
of time
[Music]
organising transport on a ship just out
of Detroit he was getting closer but
he'll still 37 miles away from Ann Arbor
he began a long and steady hike towards
his destination he noticed that Isaak
startling of clear readings it now
showed Ronson as being just south of Ann
Arbor
on reaching the campus he spent several
hours searching before eventually coming
across a small rooftop fire on the South
University as it began slowly moving
forwards he noticed a woman in a
division agent Diaz quietly assists the
situation and it didn't take long for
him to realize that the woman was April
he could tell from their body language
that she wasn't a captive which also
meant that Ronson hadn't yet found out
what information she had Diaz decided a
straightforward approach was best and so
he stepped out of the darkness and it
reduced himself he told him he had
reports of the civilian wearing division
gear in this location so he was there
checking it out this led to April
explaining how she'd come across the
gear and that she'd taken it from the
division agent who died saving her life
it was getting late and April expressed
that she needed to go to sleep but just
before she drifted off she explained to
Diaz how her and raphson had met
according to her Bronson had saved her
life
on the way to Ann Arbor Diaz began to
realize that this is how Ronson must
have gained her trust that she had no
idea what he was really after and that
Ronson was just building up their
relationship so that she would drop her
guard and give the information he was
sent to retrieve it could have been
exhaustion or maybe it was the fact she
was in the presence of two division
agents and felt safe as April went on to
reveal what she had traveled so far she
spoke of her husband and how he had been
working on a new class of antivirals and
after his death his research was
potentially being used to help develop a
vaccine for the dollar flu in a lab and
Ann Arbor and tomorrow they plan to go
this facility and see if this was truly
the case and hopefully give April's some
knowledge and peace knowing her
husband's death had not been in vain
as April slipped off to sleep Diaz and
Ronson both work through the information
they've just been given Diaz knew of
such an antiviral existed that he had to
do everything in his power to ensure
that it got into the hands of the people
who would do the most good with it he
weighed up his options based on what he
knew already had every writer for The
Bulletin Ronson's head right now and
then but Ronson was also a division
agent and he had the same training as
dears
so the desired outcome was certainly not
guaranteed in fact Ronson was quite
possibly considering the same option
right now dears also needed to consider
that there was also April's welfare to
think about - regardless Diaz continues
small talk with Ronson after a long
silence
Ronson said one last thing before going
to sleep one you don't know everything
you think you know about me so I'm going
to sleep if you want to punch my ticket
that's your call if you don't wake me up
in four hours and I'll take the second
watch
deers stayed up all night since his head
injury had been struggling to sleep he
was angry that he'll starting to
second-guess his assessment of Ronson
was the death of 14 people with it to
make sure that the world would know that
help was coming that the dollar flew was
soon to become a bad memory
maybe he'd misjudged him after all he
helped make sure that April made it here
the only thing hanging India's his mind
was who are these people that Ronson
have been talking to all three of them
were now on the labs talking to our
professors in church she just confirmed
the existence of a broad-spectrum
antiviral and that the samples have been
sent off to an adviser of the President
das received a call and he'll if Thomson
and April in the room talking to the
professor bill was Hendrix she cut
straight to the point
until Diaz that he needed to get away
from that location and Ronson as soon as
possible
Bronson had made a call at 6:20 that
morning advising mantas about April the
antivirus and the location and that the
area was about to get hot and soon Diaz
calmed himself down before returning to
the room walking back into the lab
making sure not to give anything away
when he was close enough Diaz pivoted
and knocked Ronson out cold with a left
hook while tying him to a chair
April pushin what she had just witnessed
he saved my life
I wouldn't have made it this far without
him Diaz went on to explain that Robson
been tracking her since she left
Manhattan and that he had been taking
orders from the group outside of the shd
and that he had gone rogue
he continued to explain that he's been
trekking Ronson for days trying to
figure out what he's up to
and only just now has found out that
there is an attack on the compound about
to happen at any minute
there's calls the professor to flee the
room so that she could warn the JT of
guarding the facility Ronson started to
come to while still dazed deer started
pushing for answers who is mantis how
did they get you on board smiling but
obviously in pain Ronson went on to
explain that he has no idea who mantises
or the group she works for but was
hoping to find out after this operation
he explained that he was approached and
told that the JTF and government weren't
going to be able to make it through this
chaos
something that he was already starting
to feel himself that there were
humanity's last hope to make it through
to the other side dears told April that
they needed to leave before the cavalry
arrived before they made their way from
the room
Ronson told them to hurry mantises
people were planning on seizing control
of the fuel supplies up and down the
East Coast because the ones who have the
vehicles are the ones who will win
control ducking and weaving between
buildings April and dears were able to
stay outta sight of the attacking force
in their helicopters dears had planned
to help the JTF defend the compound that
they were already overwhelmed so was up
to him in April to make sure that the
message got to Washington he kept moving
for over an hour before he deemed it
safe enough to stop
Diaz knew that the Bronson's handlers
would be looking for them anyone on the
compound who knew about the anti virals
in their location will likely be dead by
the end of the day so that means there
is only three people who know about it
him April and Ronson Bronson will have
told his new friends so they needed to
tell this deers instructed April to make
her way to Washington DC and tell the
first division agent she came across
about what she had seen here and that
she needs to hurry he also requested
that she check up on his kids if she had
time after she'd spoken to an agent Diaz
wasn't gonna be coming with her as much
as he wanted to see his children he felt
obliged to do everything he could to
stop the invading force from tecnica
troll of the fuel facilities up and down
the coast he handed April some extra
ammunition for a gun and gave her
directions for the best route to take
he also handed her Ronson's division
watch he said this will get their
attention and this is the last we hear
of Diaz as far as the story goes was he
successful did he make it back to his
children Ward did he perish at the hands
of this invading force I like to think
he put up a good fight against the black
tusk but is yet to make it back to
Washington DC the fight is obviously
still going on and he's likely still in
the thick of it but I don't think this
is last we'll hear of him
like I did in the April Kalahari Oh I
urge you to get the broken dawn book if
you have them already this has really
just been a summary of Aurelio dia as a
story if you really want to get into the
nitty-gritty of what it was like being a
division agent this book does a
fantastic job of articulating it I'll
have some completely non affiliated
links in the description if you'd like
to check them out and if you'd like to
feed my desperate need for social
acceptance you'll also find links to my
Twitter Instagram and other various
social media anyway thank you very much
for watching I hope you've enjoyed this
and I'll catch you in the next one
Cheers
you